it was my first boyfriend I almost don't
want to give this one he doesn't get
BuzzFeed airtime okay hello we are the
cast wine country and we are gonna play
BuzzFeed's BFF game we're gonna see what
kind of friends we are and how much we
know about each other and once we get it
right you get to drink okay I love that
kind of wolf no you want to pick a card
go first yes I will all right yeah you
just said it every time that's one all
right all right
oh my god you guys are amazing
[Laughter]
[Music]
last night last night also are sincerely
two to one and a half three oh I love
that you think I can handle my liquor
alas I think one and a half I don't know
[Music]
but I'm close I know when your birthday
is but I don't know when but I'm on a
cusp you're not a Libra cause pearls a
Libra really Wow cuz I'm on that card
this is where it starts I mean my real
friends know it but not your fake movie
front okay
fighting sweet liquor man I said milk no
sugar I said you don't you drink tea
I think recovered that this is lentil
payback softball payback time
you know the hockey closest is Spivey
with soccer but I was only on JV soccer
I played when I was a sophomore we're
all in JD and junior
oh my friends moved up diversity except
me but you know what I was in the school
play and I played in Frank
[Laughter]
I like there is what you call a lentil
thank you for watching this and don't
forget to check out one country on
Netflix Natan wine country
not wine County my mom keeps asking
about wine County its wine country